[Music]
on february 14 2019 valentine's day
jesse smallhead sat down for an
interview with the most credulous person
and also the best paid person on
television robert roberts
to describe his fake hate crime here's
what he said as i was crossing the
intersection i heard empire
and i don't answer to empire
on any empire
and i didn't answer i kept walking and
then i heard
empire
so i turned around and i said did you
just say to me how did i see
the uh attacker
uh masked
and
he said
this maggot country
punches me right in the face i was just
jumped
and i then i looked down and i see that
there's a rope around my neck
if there's a rope around my neck in
downtown chicago at two in the morning
and way back from the subway because
i don't like donald trump it happens a
lot in chicago
so as he was giving that interview and
robin roberts was nodding oh jesse yes
the people who beat him up were in
custody in chicago they're called the
osandario brothers they're from nigeria
and they were giving police the evidence
that ultimately led to the convictions
we just saw
now smollett's lawyer is promising that
conviction will be overturned we thought
it'd be interesting to hear from the
attorney for the aston dario brothers
her name is gloria rodriguez and we're
very glad to join have her join us
tonight gloria thanks so much for coming
on so what do your clients think of all
of this
oh my goodness tucker well let me just
say first and foremost
that when you first had me on it was
pretty early on after this
you know hoax came on
and i came back on your show first
because you promised me
that you would follow this story
correctly and portray it correctly and
true to your word you did and you've
gotten it right since day one on this so
i'm i'm happy to be back
and um
here talking to you about what happened
and you and i both knew what really
happened and uh the osunaro brothers are
very thrilled and and grateful that the
jury you know
didn't buy the fake act
well yeah i mean it must have been
bewildering for them since they were
there and they knew exactly what
happened to hear
jesse smallitt describe this fantasy
with a straight face i mean
what kind of person could do that
you know it's it's you're right to take
the stand if you're the defendant
um it carries obvious risks with it but
it's not your right to lie to the jury
it's you don't have the right to make up
your own set of facts and um one of the
uh osp the office of special prosecutors
my favorite part of this trial was
watching sam mendenhall what an amazing
attorney from that team he kept saying
in his closing remarks you're entitled
to your own opinions you're not entitled
to your own facts and that's what mr
smolep kept trying to do is just change
the facts
and
as much as he tried to sell that story
it just didn't make any sense and you
have to consider the osun gyro brothers
testified for two days they were not you
know they didn't have any way of knowing
the testimony of the other and they went
into significant
details
about what went on and all of this was
corroborated by the police
oh yeah but i wonder though i mean
there's so much lying just in our
society if i can just say and you begin
to think well maybe people believe it
you don't know whether they believe it
and you have a jury i don't know who's
on it but just like normal americans
and i did wonder like will they believe
this stuff were you worried at all about
the outcome
no i wasn't worried about the outcome i
mean
sorry to say that so bluntly
i mean you know there are juries that
are unpredictable at times but this is
one of those cases tucker um and i know
you covered this on your show so i won't
belabor it but there was a mountain
of evidence uh to show that every detail
that the osondario brothers were saying
was corroborated they said for instance
that they did a dry run on that you know
saturday before the event and the police
were able to track down jesse's car and
so what plausible
you know viable theory could jesse give
for all those exact things it's just
nothing he said was cohesive or made
sense right i know but for those of us
who so desperately want to believe in
our justice system above all systems in
this country this was a thrilling result
because it was reality based and i love
that you never doubted it thank you for
coming on tonight it's great to see you
again
thank you tucker great to be on and
feliz navidad amen feliz navidad